moin Axel moin Christoph meine
nutzerfrage ist woher nimmst du die
Inspiration für deine Songs und da du
diese Frage ja wahrscheinlich schon
öfter gehört hast wür mich interessieren
woher hast du speziell die Inspiration
für den Song Alter Strand genommen und
wenn es diesen Ort wirklich gibt wo
liegt der danke schön für die
Beantwortung und
sch ja finde ich gut guter Typ gutes
T-Shirt vor allen Dingen sehr
sympathisch und da hinten sehe ich sind
das Pferde eigentlich nee ich kann
erkennen genau die Inspiration für der
alte Strand ist ganz einfach erklärt
also seitdem ich
null bin musste ich mit meinen Eltern
immer auf die Nordseeinsel Amrum fahren
die aber sehr schön ist und wir haben
entweder auf dem zellplatz gewohnt oder
im ganzen im Norden der Insel und in der
alte Strand geht es um folgendes
als ich dann vor das sind jetzt auch
schon wieder so 4er F Jahre ist es her
als ich dann dahingfahren bin ähm eben
schon so ein bisschen größer ist es
wirklich so passiert dass ich Leute
wieder getroffen habe die ich wirklich
seit 15 Jahren nicht mehr getroffen habe
und und die mit ihrer Familie dann auch
schon Kinder und in dem Falle sogar ein
Hund eben auch wieder da waren
und der Song geht irgendwie darum dass
man sich wieder trifft und das es
irgendwie seltsam ist ne was aus dem
einen geworden ist also der eine ist
dick geworden der andere ist unglücklich
geworden der eine ist ganz groß geworden
und ganz dünn und hat irgendwie ist das
dritte Mal schon geschieden und so hat
man sich so wieder getroffen um sich am
Ende oben an der Bar die es auch immer
noch gab oben an den Dünen auf dem bchen
zu treffen und zu sagen das doch
eigentlich eine schöne Zeit und das war
meine Inspiration also ist eigentlich
eine wahre
Geschichte